RYAN BOYD: Hi everyone,
welcome back.
My name is Ryan Boyd.
I'm a developer advocate at
Google in the Cloud Platform.
And I'm serving as your
emcee here today.
Next up, we have Chris from
Google and Rafael from
RightScale to talk about
creating amazingly scalable
games on the Google
Cloud Platform.
This pretty much ties together a
lot of the technologies that
we talked about in the first
session of the day today, ties
together Compute Engine, App
Engine, BigQuery, and Storage
all together to create games
which scale really well.
So, Chris?
CHRIS ELLIOTT: Thanks, Ryan.
That definitely summarized
it pretty good.
So my name's Chris Elliott.
I'm a solutions architect on
the Cloud Platform team.
It's kind of funny internally
at Google.
We're a very engineering driven
company, so I often get
asked, like, what do you do
as a solutions architect?
People don't really understand
internally.
But I essentially work with
people, with developers, to
help me build massive
distributed systems to
leverage the power of the
Google Cloud Platform.
And specifically, I work very
closely with a lot of game
developers who are just doing--
the amount of things
you guys are doing
is mind-blowing.
Especially when you combine a
platform like Google with
amazing ideas, every day I'm
blown away with what people
are creating.
So this talk, Amazingly Scalable
Games on Google.
And it really breaks down
to three core messages.
The first one is really speed.
Speed not only in terms of
development speed, of building
up and deploying your game as
quick as possible by not
focusing on building out the
core infrastructure, but also
speed in terms of sheer
speed of the platform.
Technology like Compute Engine,
developers are pushing
in amazing ways and really
leveraging that powerful
performance.
Second up really is scale.
Scale, in terms of the
amount of huge
resources Google has available.
At Google I/O we did sort of a
demo of how much that actually
is, but also in terms of
scaling correctly.
If you only have two users and
you're testing and getting the
ball just rolling, you should
only be using the resources
that are required for two.
Vice versa, once you get to a
million users, you need to be
able to seamlessly
scale up to that.
And that's really
the underlying
message of the talk.
And lastly and most
importantly, it's
heartbreaking when you see
amazing games with a huge
amount of effort poured into
them have issues at launch
because they become successful,
they're huge,
everybody wants to play them
and the back end services
cannot keep the game going.
I mean, it's tragic.
And it's really about surviving
that unexpected
success, or surviving traffic
that's way beyond your
craziest expectations and be
able to handle that so that
everything works out smoothly.
And on that sort of morbid
side note, the game plan
really is to go over Google
Compute Engine because that
really is a powerful feature for
enabling a lot of things
developers need to
do on a platform.
Next up is really
the main show.
It's how do you tie together all
of these components of the
Google Cloud Platform to solve
really challenging problems?
How to leverage each of the
components to the best of
their ability to focus on
solving the right problems and
leveraging the technology to
where it performs best.
And then finally, when you're
building on GC, RightScale is
a very compelling technology to
help solve some challenging
problems there.
And we'll discuss how that
fits into the reference
architecture as well as how
people are using it in general
on Compute Engine.
So without further ado,
let's jump into the
Compute Engine Overview.
And with this, it's a service we
announced at last I/O, and
it's infrastructure
as a service.
You get raw, virtual
machines to run in
Google's Data Center.
And I mean, honestly, is there
anybody in this room who would
not want their code executing
in a data center like that?
That's absolutely gorgeous.
I've seen some pretty crazy data
centers at past jobs that
are just not where you'd
want your code running.
And that is one awesome
looking data center.
There might have been a little
bit of extra lights added for
the photo shoot, but nobody's
confirmed or denied that yet.
But really what your looking
at, leveraging with Compute
Engine, is utilizing Google's
scale, their speed.
And actually one of the most
impressive things is the
global footprint.
The fact that we have fiber
connecting all of our data
centers, you start to lose the
concept of having regions that
are completely independent.
You can actually have
really great
performance between regions.
And you can view it really as
just an interconnected grid of
data centers all
over the world.
And when you utilize that,
it's very compelling.
And throughout this
presentation, there are really
four guiding principles that
come up time and time again.
Consistency is huge.
When you're building out on a
cloud platform, if you do an
implementation, a proof of
concept, you need to expect
that exact same performance
from those instances
regardless of there's one or
100,000 instances spun up.
And with that, it's almost
challenging some preconceived
notions people have about
cloud computing.
There's some practices common
on other platforms where you
spin up 1,000 instances, you run
performance tests, you see
what gets to disks.
And if it's a terrible
performance,
you throw it away.
Don't do that on
Compute Engine.
You're wasting your
time and money.
Because the instance should
perform exactly the same
regardless of where it is and
what's running on it.
We strive always to go for
consistency and have a
consistent level of performance
as opposed to a
massive variable swing.
And also very important
is security.
I mean, I also have not got
anybody to confirm about the
stormtrooper in our
data center.
But actually R2-D2--
I guarantee there'll be R2-D2s
in our data centers.
We're huge fans of robots.
And even at my desk back
in California--
well, Mountain View--
I have a Nerf robot that is
telepresence controlled.
I can drive it anywhere on
campus and troll my coworkers
whether or not I'm in and out.
So I would expect the exact same
crazy guys in the data
centers to be spending their
spare weekends hacking on
robots as well.
So that's pretty much
guaranteed.
But really with Compute Engine,
it's about allowing
developers to do what they want
to be open and flexible
and really allow them to benefit
from Google's proven
technology.
And so these principles come
up time and time again.
And gaming customers are
really noticing this.
Kunal from Phyken Media was
moving all their game servers
to Compute Engine.
And it was amazing.
Our second time we talked he
came up and he's like,
everything is just noticeably
faster on Compute Engine.
What are you guys doing?
I forgot to mention the amazing
network performance.
And it's great when it's not a
matter of looking the logs and
seeing no second improvement.
It's actually in-game from
the application.
When you click on an action,
it responds faster.
It performs as you'd expect.
And this kind of message comes
up again and again from
everybody we talked to.
So it's really cool stuff what
they're able to do there.
And it's amazing when it's not
even a placebo effect, it's
actually people experiencing
it and then
telling you about it.
It's great to see.
And so at a high level overview,
here are the four
core components of
Compute Engine.
This is not a super
deep technical
overview of Compute Engine.
I can talk for hours about
all these components.
And if you're interested in
that, I'd love to talk to you
afterwards.
It's more of a higher
level overview.
And if you're interested in much
more detailed content,
there's some great sessions from
I/O last year, look to
this year's I/O as well.
And also the developer docs
has a ton of detail.
So this is just a high level
overview of how the components
fit together and what
you look at.
And so at the core of it is
the Linux virtual machines
that are running in
the data center.
That is the speed, the
core performance.
That is really the heart
of the system.
And the other technology's
really about augmenting that
and helping solve challenging
problems by using that core,
raw computing power.
And so on that, you're looking
at three types of disk store
for when you're storing objects
or files, et cetera.
Persistent disk is very common
for mission critical data.
This lives beyond the life
of the instance.
And what's really interesting
about persistent disk is
performance is good
by default.
And also, it's consistent.
The level of performance is
exactly the same regarding
when you're using it,
how many you have,
where they're attached.
And so you can rely on that
when building it out.
And also, it's all encrypted
by rest.
And so there's some features
that are really compelling a
lot of people to do things they
hadn't been able to do
before as easy as this.
The other option is local
or ephemeral disk.
And this really is if you
need to write logs
out, scratch disk.
It lives and dies with
the instance.
And on the consistency as well,
if you have four cores,
you actually have your own
dedicated spindle.
So you're the only project
using that spindle.
So you can rely on the
performance of that as well.
But once again, it lives and
dies with the instance.
We can never get that back,
especially since all the
data's encrypted at rest.
And finally, the last really big
component of the system is
Google Cloud Storage.
And when you're building up
large scale distributed
systems, this is really where
you need to look to store game
files, game binaries, all
the assets there.
Or if you have all these log
files on your local disk,
keeping them stored long term
in Cloud Storage to use for
MapReduce pipelines later on.
That's really how to think
about these three core
technologies and how
they fit together.
And there's more on that later
in the reference architecture.
The networking.
This is huge for gaming
companies, and it's opening up
new possibilities.
The latency to connect
to Compute Engine is
fantastically fast.
I can't believe I just said
I think I stole that
from Michael
Manoochehri who's up later.
He loves using that
word when talking
about BigQuery as well.
But that's a side
note I guess.
But the networking performance
is great.
And also within regions, the
private network, being able to
have a direct private fiber
network between all of your
instances and regions allows for
very impressive throughput
and very impressive latency.
And so the technology is there
to enable these new kind of
experiences with gaming.
And it also makes ones that
previously didn't fit great in
the cloud actually work well.
And the last aspect
really is the API.
And this is built on tried
and true Google
RESTful API OAuth 2.
If you've ever used any Google
API , you know exactly what to
expect here.
And as we're Google, we build on
top of that exact same API
when putting together command
line tools, building out
libraries, et cetera.
So it's robust, it's true.
And it allows you to actually
access all of these items as
you would expect.
And so that's really
the Compute
Engine high level overview.
But really, as a solutions
architect, the key thing is
thinking that it's not
just Compute Engine.
When building out on the
platform, you need to think
about all of the different
technologies that are provided
to make sure you leverage the
ones that are best for doing
the job you're actually
tackling.
And so the Compute Engine
interfaces with a lot of the
other products we
provide as well.
For example, if you want to use
Queues from App Engine,
which was talked about earlier,
or if you want to put
files to Cloud Storage, the
command line utility to do
that is already set-- you can
have that set up by default
when creating an instance.
So there's a lot of seamless
connections here.
And we're always working to make
that even more seamless
in the future.
And the last couple of parts on
the Compute Engine overview
really is giving examples of
what people have seen that
really put facts behind these
things I'm saying.
I could easily stand up here
and say all these amazing
things, then we get in and it's
not what you experience.
But this is actually
what people are
experiencing on the platform.
This is from Ed with PA
consulting, and they work
closely on a product
called Chrome Jam.
Has anybody tried Chrome
Jam in the audience?
You should try it.
It's fantastic.
It basically allows
you to go in.
And you request a place
to jam with friends.
You send an invite to three
friends, and you all get
guitars, drums, et cetera.
And you can all play real-time
with the instruments and have
a jam session, essentially.
And they've done a lot of work,
actually, making that
game play really fun.
And so basically, this is the
quote he said after trying it
out on Compute Engine, "you
latency crazy low.
You should pat the Compute
Engine team on the back for
that."
After I got this quote I sent
it off to the Compute Engine
networking team and let them
know that people are still
appreciating the amazing hard
work they're doing.
It's blowing away everybody
when they
first get on the platform.
And with this, an interesting
note is they actually tried
implementing this.
The requirements for latency are
extremely tight when they
were dealing with
real-time audio.
And the fact of the matter is,
it wasn't possible on some
other platforms to even run this
technology, but it worked
on Computer Engine, which
was really, really cool.
And this one is actually
really relevant
for gaming as well.
MapR broke the Terasort world
record on Compute Engine a
couple months ago.
And what's really amazing and
relevant about this is the
fact that the previous record
was held by data centers with
dedicate machines in their
own environment.
And it was actually beaten
by a cloud platform.
Nobody would have expected this
was even possible just
because of the past experiences
working with cloud.
But that consistency, the
performance, the networking
allows you to have all of
your instances run.
You didn't have any idle
instances getting stuck or
hung because of poor
performance.
Everything spun up, processed,
shut down, and allowed them to
smash this record with a third
of the number of cores.
And so in thinking about
building out game services,
and if you're actually in that
situation of we want to build
our dedicated capacity,
seriously look at cloud
platform for potentially
allowing you to have provision
capacity where the game
is successful.
If you end up having a bunch of
capacity, you've probably
heard this before, in East Coast
and your games end up
being a huge success in Europe
and you don't have the
capacity there, something like
Cloud Platform is a perfect
way to start scaling up once you
verify the core technology
works great on the platform.
And really, the last one, this
is an article that came out
recently that when
we saw it posted
everybody internally just--
we get really fired up about
this when we see people
externally excited about
the platform.
And this was from Scalar,
Sebastian.
He put up this article.
And the inter-region latency
was under 23 milliseconds
between two regions.
That actually opens
up possibilities.
For example, if you're doing
real-time gaming, if you're
over 90 milliseconds or near 90
milliseconds, by the time
it hits the player, their
latency is going to be so high
it will remind them of being
back on 56K modems.
And nobody's going
to play that.
But if you actually have 23
milliseconds between data
centers consistent, that allows
you to actually do some
new things there as well with
actually connecting the
instances across zones.
And also if you look at the
bandwidth, the bandwidth is
off the charts, 300 megabits
per second.
And that's really, once again,
telling the story of the
Google Global Network there.
And this one, although it
technically doesn't affect the
core performance you see running
the game servers, the
time to boot up instances
is exceptionally fast.
And I was talking to Rafael from
RightScale who's going to
come up later, and I couldn't
remember the last time I
actually sat around waiting
for an instance to be
provisioned.
I go on the web UI, spin
up some instances.
By the time I get my terminal
up and go to SSH in, the
instance is already
there ready to go.
So it's new ways of thinking
that are really being observed
as well by people when they
get up and running.
And so some of you may have
tried for access.
The response has been
overwhelming.
But game developers
are a fantastic
fit for Compute Engine.
It's currently limited
to preview.
But if you'd like access,
either talk to me right
afterwards, we can get you in.
Game developers are a perfect
fit for the platform.
Otherwise, sign up for
the newsletter.
Follow the blog.
Check out cloud.google.com for
latest updates, or send me
email after the fact if you have
an interesting use case.
It's just great to hear
from game developers.
And we can definitely
get in the platform.
I wouldn't be up here talking
about Compute Engine, how
amazing it is, and then
not let anybody in.
That would be ridiculous evil.
And last time I checked,
we weren't an evil
company as of yet.
It's pretty good stuff.
Not that we ever plan to be.
So with that this is really
the main course.
How do you tie all of the
components together to solve
really challenging scalability
problems faced by developers?
And with that we had to find a
game to demonstrate this on.
And this was a perfect
candidate.
There's a game called GRITS
that they showed
off at I/O last year.
It was fantastic.
It was player versus player,
real-time, no JS on Compute
Engine using HTML5.
And it was meant to show off
the performance of what web
technology can actually do.
And so we took this core game
that had some scalability
built into it and applied a lot
of the core concepts from
this reference architecture to
this existing game, which
Google owned all the source
codes, so it made licensing
not a problem at all.
Actually, Fred in the
audience worked on
some of that as well.
And so it's an amazing point to
start to demonstrate, this
huge amount of effort spent
creating this game.
Just a little bit more, an extra
week or two, you can
start to apply some of these
concepts to allow this to
seamlessly autoscale in the
background and handle a huge
amount of traffic.
And so it's a top down,
robot shooting game.
It's awesome.
Check it out if you
have a chance.
There'll be more links
at the end.
And so this gaming reference
architecture really is about
creating real-time multiplayer
on dedicated servers, having
your own binaries running on
Compute Engine, providing
low-latency, TCIP full duplex
connections to handle all of
that streaming, running whatever
existing software you
want, while providing the
scalability to go up to
millions of users,
handle the huge
number of incoming requests.
And really it's about building
a full-featured gameplay
experience.
It's about having a store,
having a marketplace, having
things to draw players
back and thinking
about the whole package.
And this also ties together
all the components of the
Cloud platform, like
Ryan mentioned.
From using App Engine to head
a lot of the user-facing
scalable aspects to if you have
100,000 servers and they
need to actually connect to a
source of truth, using App
Engine for that and scaling as
well accordingly and things
like Cloud Storage for large
object store log files.
BigQuery, which is an amazing
tool for real-time analytics
of ridiculously huge
data sets.
And we actually don't use Cloud
SQL in this as well.
But it's exactly what
you'd expect from
a managed SQL database.
And so if you're really familiar
with that technology,
you have a good use case that
fits within the scalability
constraints of MySQL.
It's a great fit
there as well.
So to get started, you have
to be game client.
I'm sure there's no
surprises here.
The only question I've got,
actually-- we didn't have time
to change it-- is that that
Android phone looks a lot like
an iPhone, completely
accidental.
But so it's really about
regardless of whatever phone
you want to use, whether it's
iOS, Android, you have Android
application.
Or if you are developing
console games, or games
running on PC clients, or if
you're just a web browser
game, regardless you have to
start somewhere with the core
gaming aspect and building out
that client, whether it's
downloaded or obtained
over the web.
And so for GRITS, this is
what was provided by
the existing product.
And so there's an Android
application.
This just shows you
the controls.
And then also, when you connect
to the IP address
there, you're pretty
much good to go.
And you're jumping in and
playing a server connected.
And you pull all the data
content from the server as
well and play all
in the browser.
That was the really awesome
thing about GRITS.
And so once you have the client
installed, you have to
go in and find a match.
As everyone in the audience
knows, server matchmaking can
be ridiculously challenging
depending on the techniques
you use, the ways you go
about implementing it.
And the key aspect here is
really leveraging the
scalability of App Engine.
We highlighted a lot of this
in the keynote and the key
components here.
But really it's technology like
the App Engine Data Store
which is a huge NoSQL database
built on top of Megastore that
can scale up to serve millions
and millions of users.
At last I/O we said it was over
two trillion operations
per month, I believe,
or per week.
And I mean that, as you can
expect, can continue to grow.
And so that is one of the key
components to build out a lot
of this logic.
Initially, when you put Memcache
on top for a lot of
real-time accessing, if when you
have server data that is
frequently accessed, memcache is
a free layer to put on top
of that to help scale
up there.
And also if you're doing a lot
of background processing, if
you're keeping lists of
servers under certain
categories updated, you can use
things like Task Queues
and background processes
for that.
And so really those are the core
technologies to use when
building up the logic.
Whether it's something like
having all of your servers
maintain health checks with
App Engine and having that
status also in the Data Store
for future reference--
at the end of the day, it's
about what do you return from
the server matchmaking, whether
it's a simple quick
match, give me the best match
with players of my skill, or
they're actually looking at
building out something that
returns a large list of IP
addresses to the client to
allow them to find the
low-latency ones
that are close by.
That's really the core aspect
there of server matchmaking.
And there are lots of
interesting techniques if you
want to talk about that after
the fact as well.
And actually, Cloud Endpoint's
here as well.
It's kind of fun in this diagram
having a cloud and
then leaving the cloud.
All the right hand side is in
the cloud for the most part.
But Cloud Endpoint is a
fantastic technology for
having a strong RESTful API
around App Engine to provide a
way of scaling out, to have
authentication built in.
And there's also libraries
available for all the Android,
iOS, JavaScript as well to
make that really easy and
seamless to get up and
running with these
powerful RESTful APIs.
Because a lot of people building
an App Engine put a
RESTful API.
And now that's provided to you
leveraging Google's experience
building out these API.
And so for GRITS, we took a
reasonably straightforward
approach to implementing this.
And so this is what we added to
the existing application.
So essentially, when you log in
you either can do a Quick
Game, just give me a server
that has players on it.
Or you can also see a list of
all the servers you have here.
Right now there's only five.
But as this scales up the
servers are added to the
bottom of the list.
And so you can currently see
the IP addresses, how many
players are currently active.
You can go in and access
the admin as well.
So it's fairly basic.
But it gives you a general idea
of how App Engine is the
spot you go to get matched
with your server.
And then from there, once you
have that IP address, you
directly connect to the client,
and you're good to go.
And so the next aspect-- and
I mean this is, as game
developers, where the
majority of the
effort should be focused--
is building those really
compelling experiences running
on the dedicated servers,
running whatever existing
software you have, the game
engines that you develop on,
having that full connection.
This is where the player's
going to spend the
majority of the time.
And having that deployed across
regions is really
compelling.
Actually, a note on the Compute
Engine as well, the
consistent performance is really
important for dedicated
game servers.
When you look at the situation,
if 5% of your
servers aren't performing well,
5% players are going to
have a bad time.
And most likely, some of
those will actually be
very vocal about it.
And it's not going to be a
good experience overall.
And so by having that consistent
performance it
allows you to play 100,000
servers and actually know that
that performance will
be what you expect.
And you can sleep safe at night
for that one aspect.
Building scalable
systems is hard.
But the end goal is to really
allow developers to sleep
better at night and have Google
engineers and SREs on
call for a lot of the scalable
problems that are involved
with building out large
distributed systems.
So on GRITS this is exactly what
it looks like after you
click on one of those
IP addresses.
You'll see that the--
actually you probably might
not be able to see it.
But the address bar is now the
actual IP address of the
server you're connecting to.
You can put DNS on top of
that if you wanted.
Otherwise, you're directly
connected to Compute Engine
server, running no JS, pulls
in all the assets.
And you're pretty much good to
go, respond, run around,
update other players, and
start having fun.
It's actually really funny,
every time I show this off--
I was presenting at Google.
And there was about
50 people there.
And afterwards, I noticed there
was about 40 people in
the servers.
And so I felt pretty bad for the
guy in the talk afterwards
because everyone was on their
laptop actually playing.
So I had to kind of shut
those down to be nice.
But they were back up
after the fact.
And so this really highlights
the source of truth aspect.
If you have 100,000 game servers
and you want to do
things like save end of match
statistics, being able to post
those to App Engine through
Cloud Endpoints and the
RESTful API that's provided and
store those long-term in
the Data Store is a really
important aspect there.
And the Data Store is fantastic
when you're scaling
up to millions of users.
The underlying Megastore
technology, that's its bread
and butter is scaling to
millions of users, storing all
of that data in a way,
and having cross-user
transactions, et cetera
when you start
looking at user groups.
And so this can also
be the simplest as
complex as you want.
If you actually want to build it
up that every single action
is sent off every second to
App Engine, App Engine can
scale up to handle that.
The thing you need to think
about is actually scaling up
to handle that takes
a lot of resources.
And Cloud Platform, it's
pay by resources.
So you need to really understand
the cost associated
if you want to make those
engineering decisions.
Otherwise, things like if you
have a store and you have a
free to play model, keeping
track of everything that's
happening there and making sure
that if a player has a
customization on a client,
that they actually have
purchased the required
components and have the rights
to use them.
And so that's really where App
Engine provides a scalable
infrastructure to handle any
of those in-game requests.
And last aspect of App Engine
really is the virtual machine
orchestration.
If you're running 100,000 game
servers, you need to start
thinking about-- well, well
before you hit 100,000,
otherwise that's going to
be a lot of SSHing.
And it's going to be
a massive team.
But you really need to think
about how do I scale this in a
way that makes sense?
And so if you have a region
that is running out of
capacity how do--
oh, sorry, throat's a little bit
dry up here-- you utilize
the GCE API from App
Engine to call out
and create more instances?
Similarly, if players are not
currently active, you can pull
those instances from
server matchmaking.
Once all the players leave, you
can also turn that down
through the API.
So App Engine can really be
used to build out that
orchestration component.
Because it also scales up to if
you have 100,000 machines
giving [? heart, ?]
basically checking in, the
infrastructure can scale up to
handle that number
of requests.
And it can be as complex or as
simple as you want as well.
So you can have an API console,
and [INAUDIBLE]
console we go in and say, give
me another 100 instances, or
you can do some autoscaling.
So with GRITS, we did a fairly
straightforward autoscaling
algorithm here where
essentially--
this is the admin console
by the way--
once capacity reaches a certain
threshold within a
region, new game servers will
automatically be spun up and
added to be the rotation
there.
So it starts off with five by
the default configuration, but
I've scaled this up 20, 30,
40 servers very easily.
And I haven't had a chance
to actually push it.
But the underlying core
infrastructure of spinning up
those servers is exactly the
same and repeatable all the
way up to 100,000 servers.
If you start hitting 100,000
with the sample application,
you'll start to need to do a
little bit more tweaks with
server matchmaking just not to
provide a list of 100,000
servers to players.
That wouldn't be a
good experience.
But the core fundamentals of
scaling [INAUDIBLE] that looks
like from App Engine is
provided by the sample
application here.
And so this is the last aspect
of the solution is the past
component was really about the
game play experience and what
players take.
I feel bad for people
taking pictures.
There's one more part
added to this.
So unless you want to go through
the pictures and
slowly see it build
itself magically--
The last aspect is you're going
to have a huge amount of
data being generated on all
of these game servers.
And this log data can be very
valuable for a lot of business
decisions and even understanding
what your
players are doing.
And so taking those logs from
ephemeral disk and keeping
them permanently stored in
cloud storage, which is a
large online object store, it's
a great place for those
logs to live for a long time.
And what people are doing is
essentially then taking those,
running MapReduce pipelines on
it to aggregate it down to a
level they actually
care about.
So for example, if you have
every single player action per
day, that is a huge amount of
data they you're not going to
be able to wrap your
mind around.
But if you take it down to
actions per player per day and
not every single actions, it
starts to get to a level of
granularity you can actually
start looking at.
And that's really where
the next thing--
oh, wrong way in the slides.
This is the final thing here.
This is really where BiqQuery
comes into play as well, which
is a real-time tool for doing
analytics over billions of
rows of data in real-time.
We're talking seconds
to return.
And so you can do things like
AB testing or see what the
effect of a double experience
weekend is on player
engagement.
You can do a lot of these
queries that you don't really
need to have off of the top of
your head right away and build
your MapReduce pipeline.
But you can do it after
the fact ad hoc.
And before joining the Cloud
Platform team, I worked on
AdSense at Google.
And this was my bread and
butter, building out these
MapReduce BigQuery--
they really are a
dynamic duo--
that can solve ridiculous
scalable big data problems.
And so with ads, for example,
looking at all of the ad
traffic per website per day.
And then being able to go and
to look at a huge range of
sites every day or look at
things like how partners are
performing, being able to
go in after the fact and
troubleshoot if specific
sites are not
performing as expected.
So it's really powerful.
And the session happening
after this by Michael
Manoochehri will provide some
more insight to what people
are doing with BigQuery because
it's absolutely amazing.
And so this slide is going
away slowly for
anybody else who--
it's actually also published
online if you
want to look at it.
There'll be a link at the end.
So that's just really
highlighting some of the core
functionality.
But really it's about building
a full featured gameplay
experience, having user profiles
configuration, seeing
after match stats, looking in to
that player configuration.
Go in and build out your
mecs as necessary.
And starting to build
in some social
aspects, events, new feeds.
If you're free to play, you're
going to need to have some
market plays, even if you're
not, to allow players to keep
that engagement, to highlight
really interesting things they
can purchase, and build that
into the core game logic, and
start to build out friends
and favorites.
I mean, there's a million
different ways you can build a
full-featured game play
experience to keep people
coming back.
And the platform of App Engine
and Compute Engine can really
scale to handle that and allow
you to build that out in a way
that you can be rest assured
that it's going to scale out.
And so regarding GRITS, there's
a dedicated game
server solution paper
I put out.
It's available on
cloud.google.com resources.
You can find it there
as well as other
ones our team's producing.
Also the sample code is going to
come very, very, very soon.
We're literally about to
press the button on it.
And so keep an eye on the GitHub
Google Cloud Platform
for all the samples there, and
to keep an eye out for the
scalable GRITS example put in.
And so now I'd like to introduce
Rafael on stage to
talk a little bit about
RightScale, how
they play into this.
He's a senior systems
architect at
RightScale as well.
And so when looking at just that
past example, by the way,
anybody impressed with
is all Google Docs.
I mean, this is Google
presentation.
I wanted to give the audience
3D glasses, but marketing
didn't really approve of that.
But really when looking at
RightScale, this is one of be
examples where it can come
into play to solve some
amazingly challenging problems
with scalability.
So orchestrating virtual
machines can become very
complex as you scale.
And although you could build
on an App Engine, if you're
familiar or you want to
leverage tools like
RightScale, it's a perfect place
to come in and start
managing scaling up all of these
game servers in a way
that's repeatable, easy to
monitor, easy manage, easy to
overall keep it up and running
with speed and leveraging the
performance.
So on that, I'll hand
it off to Rafael.
RAFAEL SAAVEDRA: Thank
you, Chris.
So I'd like to start with a
quick overview of RightScale.
Some of you might not
know about it.
So RightScale was founded in
2006, which in cloud time is
prehistory.
And what that means, too, is
that RightScale really
believed in the cloud vision
since the beginning.
There are currently thousands
of paying customers that are
using scale and more than
70,000 users worldwide.
We do have a free tier
that's very popular.
And about 5.5 million instances
have been launched
through the platform.
And what's interesting is that
that number is that two years
ago it was one million.
So I took four years to launch
the first million instance in
the platform.
And in two years, for 4 million
more were launched,
which is talk to the exponential
growth of the
cloud consumption.
RightScale is the first SaaS
management platform, which has
solutions built specifically
for the gaming industry.
And so what that resulted in it
is basically RightScale has
become the de facto standard
for running gaming
infrastructure on the cloud.
15 of the top 20 Facebook
games are run on top of
RightScale.
Games like Angry Birds,
CityVille, FarmVille, all use
RightScale as their management
solution.
And when other thing that I
really enjoy working at
RightScale is seeing all the
crazy things that our
customers build on top
of the platform.
And the gaming industry seems
to be some of the more
creative folks.
And so we see people already
taking automation to the
extreme and be able to achieve
ratios of 10,000 servers being
managed by one [INAUDIBLE],
which is amazing.
So why is it that game
developers choose RightScale
to manage their infrastructure?
So this is turning down
to the technical
aspects of the platform.
And basically what the platform
lets you do is write
code that gets run when an
instance is launched in the
cloud on that instance.
It also let's you run the code
that's going to get run when
instances shut down
or when some
interesting events happen.
And the platform also let's
you define what those
interesting events are.
So the platform is
going to connect
monitoring data in real-time.
And you can use that data
to create events.
So it could be that the CPU's
running hot, or you're running
low on memory, or low
on disk space.
And when those things happen,
then you can trigger some code
to run on that instance.
It's also possible to extend
those metrics.
So you can have application
specific metrics, like number
of requests per second, number
of reads per second and use
those metrics to trigger
execution of
code in those instances.
So if an app server hasn't
gotten any requests in the
past two minutes, then there's
something wrong with it.
And you can actually do
something about that.
And finally, what RightScale
lets you do is take all those
rules, all the alerts and all
this code, and wrap that into
a single unit, which we call a
sort of a template, and let's
you share that template
across your teams.
So if you have an organization
that's [INAUDIBLE] multiple
games that have similar
infrastructure requirements,
you get to actually share a lot
of that code and a lot of
that configuration logic.
That code, you can also publish
it in the marketplace.
And I will cover that in a few
slides, where you can actually
have external people from your
organization input that code
as well if that's something
that you need to do.
So once you have crafted those
ServerTemplates encapsulating
all that code an all those other
alerts, you can use that
to leverage all those gaining
by launching servers that
executive the code and
most of the template.
And the way the scaling works is
that those same alerts that
you use to trigger execution of
code when things happen you
can also use that to
trigger votes.
So an instance can vote to scale
up [INAUDIBLE] if the
CPU's running hot or can voter
to scale down if it's idle.
And then you get to choose
the threshold.
How many voters need
to be voting before
scaling even happens?
And when the scaling even
happens, you get to choose how
many instances should boot
or how many instances
should be shut down.
And there's all kinds of
other levels of knobs
that you can turn.
You can which data center those
instances should be
booted in and all kinds of other
settings that you can
specify through both the
dashboard and the REST APIs.
I have some pretty pictures
here on all those slides.
But all of that functionality
is available
through our REST APIs.
So then the monitoring data that
is used to trigger those
events is also used
to plot graphs.
So you get different
kinds of graphs.
You have simple graphs like
the one shown here.
You can also get stacked graphs
that works great if you
have a 100 or less servers.
Past 100 servers stacked graphs
start to get a little
bit useless and you want to
use things like heat maps.
So we have heat maps where the
color of the pixel indicates
the intensity of the metric.
The other thing that RightScale
lets you do is get
notifications when those
errors trigger.
So you can get an email.
You can get paged.
You can get woken up at 2:00
AM, All those great things.
And it also lets you run those
scripts on demand.
So it's not just pure
automation.
You can actually say,
OK, I need to backup
this database now.
You can click the button
and take a back up now.
And once you have all those
servers running most of
templates and those server
arrays, you can organize all
that in deployments.
And what RightScale lets you do
then is once you have those
deployments is you
can clone them.
So you can have your production
deployment, and you
can clone that.
Then have QA use that clone
to render the test code.
And if you have to test
different branch, you can
clone again and launch
in the cloud and run
that different code.
So it's very powerful.
So going back to the
marketplace, the marketplace
is a repository of previous
server templates.
And so I was counting them to
prepare for this presentation
and as of March 21 we had a
bit more than 67 templates
built for GCE.
And actually, those
ServerTemplates will run on
multiple clouds.
And 20 of which were published
by RightScale.
And what that means is that
they are supporting by
RightScale.
So if you have issues with any
of the ServerTemplates or
stacks, you can actually
send tickets and we
will look at that.
And the thing is because
we built them--
and these are the same
ServerTemplates that the
people running CityVille or
Angry Birds are using--
these are things that have best
practice built in and you
get to leverage all of that
knowledge right off the bat by
using those.
And they cover all the different
tiers that you may
use, database, application
servers, front-ends, and other
things like Syslog, Memcache,
all kinds of things.
And we also have a lot more
ServerTemplates that are going
to get ported to the [? C ?]
little by little--
a bit more than 400
ServerTemplates in the
marketplace, and they are all
going to get ported into the
[? C ?] little by little.
So at the end of the day, what
all that means is that you
spend less time managing your
infrastructure and more time
actually on the games, which
is what you want.
Some of the easiest sell we
have at RightScale is when
somebody has tried doing the VM
orchestration by piece by
themselves and realize after six
months of development that
it's going to take another
six months.
And it's not worth the effort.
You might as well just go with
a company that just does that
as a [? reading. ?]
So going back to GCE and
Google, today GCE is
completely integrated
within RightScale.
So all of the features that
RightScale provides are
available on GCE.
And that's really awesome
because you get an incredible
infrastructure.
And on top of that you get the
flexibility and the power of
RightScale.
And my little anecdote here is
about three weeks ago we
released a new revision of
our ServerTemplates.
And that means that we had to
launch about 1,000 servers to
test all the various
combinations of crowds,
platforms, software stacks, so
MySQL, using Ubuntu, MySQL
using CentOS, all of those
different combinations.
And consistently on all those
platforms and all those
software stacks you see it has
been the fastest cloud.
So I think it's a testament to
the quality of the cloud.
Now you get that quick
set up that the cloud
provides you with.
And on top of that you get the
ability that RightScale
provides to clone those
deployments.
And you end up with something
that is very powerful where
you can take your entire
infrastructure and duplicate
it in minutes.
That's basically the time it
takes to clone and launch.
But two minutes and you have
your entire infrastructure
just replicated and available
for testing.
And because it's running on GCE,
you get to publish your
assets to YouTube, Google+, and
other Google properties
without being charged for
bandwidth, which can be
significant depending on what
your game needs to do.
And I am pleased to announce
that as of today the
RightScale Social Gaming
Edition is actually
available on GCE.
So this is the same edition that
all those other games I
mentioned have been using.
And what you get with that is
both a set of software stacks,
pre-built ServerTemplates
pre-built for you to use, but
also and maybe more importantly,
you get support
and services from RightScale.
So you get an OnBoarding package
where you get to work
with the same people that have
worked with those other games.
So you get to leverage
a lot of expertise
right off the bat.
We also include some JumpStart
training so that you get quick
started on RightScale
and using the
cloud if you need that.
So I think the website is
being built as I speak.
So it's not available
just yet.
So check back on
rightscale.com during the week.
It should be there in
the next few days.
In the meantime, you
can contact me.
There will be an email address
in the next slide that you can
send me to if you are interested
in subscribing to
this program.
And I think this is it.
CHRIS ELLIOTT: Awesome.
In a nutshell and to really
wrap it all up, what we've
seen is Google Cloud Platform
is the best place for
cutting-edge developers.
Whether it's an indie or a AAA
game studio, there are people
doing amazing things
by leveraging the
power of the platform.
And really, the next time you're
going out, building a
platform, if you're already on
the platform as well, just
keep thinking about how you
can integrate all of the
components to solve the
extremely challenging game
problems that we
see every day.
So that's basically it.
And we can take any questions.
And please reach out to us if
there's anything else you're
interested in.
Feel free to use the microphone
in the middle if
you have any questions.
Otherwise, just raise
your hand and I can
repeat it as well.
All right, no questions.
That's a first I think.
Well, thank you everybody.
And keep an eye out for the
other tracks as well.